madame monsieur bonsoir l'afssa l'agencé
française de sécurité alimentaire
recommande l'enfermement systématique de
toutes les volailles sur l'ensemble du
territoire
lagence parle d'un risque aggravé de
contamination par le virus de la grippe
aviaire
le gouvernement devrait prendre sa
décision dès demain le dossier du
clemenceau désormais sur le bureau de
jacques chirac dénoncée par l'opposition
comme un fiasco
le feuilleton de l'ancien porte-avions
embarrasse le gouvernement dominique de
villepin affirme que la france se
conformera aux décisions de la justice
indienne et française
lancement aujourd'hui du plan pour
développer des services à la personne
procédure simplifiée grâce à un chèque
emploi service universel objectif
faciliter la vie des français et créer
au moins cinq cent mille emplois
mobilisation populaire aujourd'hui dans
les rues de verrous pour rendre hommage
à rafic hariri assassiné il ya tout
juste un an
près d'un million de personnes ont crié
leur attachement le liban et leur
opposition à la syrie
l'an passé les automobilistes français
ont perdu plus de 7 millions de points
sur leur permis de conduire
c'est la conséquence de la politique
répressive menée par le gouvernement
les vendeurs de scooters et de voitures
sans permis se fera pleinement
et puis on a pris ce soir la mort de
tarifs ou le comédien s'est éteint à
l'âge de 91 ans il nous laissera l'image
d'un titre exceptionnel et attachant qui
a joué dans plus de 150 et ce soir la
france semble bien s'orienter vers un
confinement total des volailles sur
l'ensemble du territoire
la salle agence française de sécurité
des aliments recommande fermement cette
mesure et l'estiment qu'il ya un risque
aggravé de contamination avec l'arrivée
de la grippe aviaire dans notre pays
edouard baer jean-bernard bonnart
vigilance maximum sur l'ensemble du
territoire et surtout dans les zones
humides sur les bords de loire se garde
chasse viêt la moindre anomalie
chez ces animaux il ya plus de 100
cadavres trouvés nous récupérons six
oiseaux que nous confions donc au
laboratoire départemental
1 direction des services vétérinaires
donc pour examen et pour déceler le cas
échéant bon grip éventuellement la
grippe aviaire selon les experts
scientifiques
le risque de contamination par le virus
h5n1 s'aggrave
aujourd'hui l' agence de sécurité
sanitaire des aliments émet des
recommandations confinement des
volailles d'élevage et vaccination pour
les animaux ne pouvant pas être enfermé
comme les oies et les canards
ceci dit les contaminations peuvent se
produire des foyers peuvent
effectivement même en dépit de
l'application de toutes ces mesures
peuvent effectivement se produire ces
mesures s'appliquent dans les zones
humides considérés comme à risque et
dans les départements d'élevage intensif
la loire atlantique la vendée les
langues
ça passe par la création de bâtiments se
montent ce ccc quelque chose c'est de
sept de ses conséquences extrêmement
décevant lourd à mettre en oeuvre ça
c'est certain
la grippe aviaire se répand en europe
après l'italie est ici la grèce
l'autriche est le troisième pays
confronté à la maladie de signes
porteurs du virus h5n1 viennent d'être
découverts dans le sud du pays est
d'ores et déjà les mesures de vigilance
et de surveillance ont été renforcées
dans les zones de transit des oiseaux
migrateurs
le parc naturel régional de camargue se
préparent à cette période sensible de
migration qui va se prolonger jusqu'à la
fin mars
yannick a aussi benoît jourdain ils
commencent à revenir des côtes
africaines de la méditerranée oies
canards et grives sous haute
surveillance grippe aviaire oblige ici
dans les marais du vigueirat des
prélèvements sont effectués chaque jour
sur des animaux sauvages et tout
cadavres d'oiseaux serait immédiatement
signalée et analyser mais pour l'instant
aucune trace du virus h5n1
si l'arrivée en camargue dans le saurez
rapidement parce que
on est sur un territoire où une grand
nombre d'institutions de gestionnaires d
espaces sont quotidiennes en contact
avec le milieu naturel
ils sont des observateurs de ce milieu
naturel et par ce réseau d'observateurs
on aurait vite de l'information les
migrateurs venant d'afrique
subsaharienne arriveront dans un à deux
mois la vigilance est donc maximale mais
pas vraiment d'inquiétude concernant une
éventuelle transmission à l'homme facile
ça touche des oiseaux sauvages
le contact entre les oiseaux sauvages et
des humains et est faible voire nul à la
chasse est fermée très officiellement
aujourd'hui
donc ce risque est faible au parc
ornithologique de pont de gau on
pourrait presque toucher les oiseaux
pourtant la fréquentation ne fléchit pas
mais jusqu'à quand on a tous une petite
crainte effectivement parce que ça ça ça
voudrait dire une remise en cause de
beaucoup d'activités en camargue et
notamment de la mythologie
ce soir les autorités françaises
recommandent la claustration où la
vaccination des volailles dans les zones
humides à risque les 80 mille hectares
du parc régional de camargue constitue
la zone d'hivernage la plus importante
de france pour les canards
hier soir nous vous parlions de
l'inquiétude après la découverte d'un
signe mort sur la plage de honfleur
en fait il n'y a aucune trace du virus
de la grippe aviaire
l'animal est décédé de façon naturelle
le feuilleton de l'ancien porte avions
clemenceau a pris aujourd'hui une
tournure très politique
jacques chirac s'est saisi du dossier
l'opposition parle de fiasco et
dominique de villepin estime lui-même
que c'est une affaire regrettable
le premier ministre qui affirme que la
france se conformera aux décisions de la
justice indienne et française alexandre
kara samuel une aise le clemenceau n'est
plus seulement un navire épave
il est devenu une affaire d'état face
aux obstacles juridiques aux critiques
politiques l'elysée annonce ce soir que
le président de la république s'est
saisi directement du dossier du porte
avions clemenceau déjà hier le chef de
l'ump avait donné le ton en envisageant
pour la première fois le rapatriement du
navy
vraiment la question finira bien finir
par se poser moi je suis comme tout le
monde je cherchais du mal à comprendre
tout ça depuis plusieurs jours déjà les
socialistes réclament le retour du clem
et dénonce l'hypocrisie du gouvernement
on peut passer être simplement
protecteur des normes sociales et des
normes environnementales en france et
pas à l'étranger
donc ça devient grotesque il faut le
rapatrier les verts vont plus loin ils
demandent la création d'une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire et surtout
accusent la ministre de la défense de
mensonges
je me souviens de michèle alliot marie
avec son fort un peu altier et son
discours très fort mais qui fois mentait
parce qu'elles ne savaient pas soit
mentait délibérément sur le tonnage
d'amiante à la terre du clemenceau c'est
de moscou puis vient la première
réaction officielle dominique de
villepin en visite en russie annonce que
le gouvernement se pliera aux décisions
des justices indienne et française la
france se conformera bien sûr aux
obligations et aux décisions de la
justice indienne et française et je
souhaite que cela puisse venir
maintenant très rapidement en début
d'après midi c'est au tour de michèle
alliot marie de confirmer que la
question du retour du clemenceau est
d'actualité pour l'elysée comme pour le
gouvernement il faut en finir au plus
vite avec ce dossier avant le début
dimanche prochain de la visite en inde
le jacques chirac en marge de ce débat
politique comment est on arrivé à cet
imbroglio départ il faut rappeler que la
france voulait trouver une solution
économique et propre démantèlement de
l'ancien porte-avions mais les obstacles
se sont multipliées thierry kurt egli au
feutre à avec le lancement du
porte-avions qui portera sur les mers le
nom de clemenceau une fierté nationale
en 1957 un encombrant boulet aujourd'hui
dont la france a bien du mal à se
débarrasser dans tous les pays les vieux
navires de guerre rouis dans des zones
d'attentes avec l'ex clemenceau l'état a
voulu innover et démanteler le vieux
tigre dassier le milicien la défense a
donc confié ce dossier à une société
spécialisée hes dei
elle a payé cent mille euros pour
valoriser la carcasse elle s'occupe de
tout c'est elle qui attribue à
l'entreprise techno pur le soin de
désamianter partiellement le navire
avant son départ
c'est elle qui loue le remorqueur jusqu
en inde c'est elle encore qui se
rembourse en vendant les métaux extraits
par le chantier indien ce qui coûte cher
dans cette opération c'est d'enlever une
partie de l'amiante en france
difficile de dire combien il en reste à
bord après quarante années d'entretien
pour la marine et sd il y en avait 160
tonnes - les 115 enlevé reste 45
pas du tout dit techno pur 2 500 à 1000
tonnes encore car un différend
commercial a surgi entre les deux
sociétés
c'est lui qui alimente encore la
polémique aujourd'hui le ministère de la
défense a depuis tenté de désamorcer la
crise en rencontrant certaines
associations qui se sont portés parties
civiles
l'effet contre-productif quand on a posé
des questions sur où et l amiante le
repérage qui avait été fait les tonnages
on s'est aperçu que il n'y avait pas de
réponse cohérente qui pouvait nous être
nous être donné un flou qui donne une
impression de gâchis sur une bonne
intention au départ
les etats-unis eux viennent de se
séparer de leurs vieux porte-avions
l'america ils l'ont tout simplement
coulé par moins de 1000 m jean louis
borloo en avait fait l'un de ses
dossiers prioritaires le ministre de
l'emploi a lancé aujourd'hui son plan
pour développer les services à la
personne garde d'enfants jardinage ou
encore aides aux personnes âgées une
vingtaine de métiers sont ainsi
concernés par ce plan dont le socle
s'appelle chèque emploi service
universel le cesu explications et mode
d'emploi julien beaumont alain dupas un
coup de propre à la maison voilà
typiquement le genre de travaux
concernés par le chèque emploi service
universel cesu qui offre quelques
avantages
fini les paperasses pour le particulier
il suffit de remplir le chèque en
indiquant les heures travaillées la
rémunération c'est le volet social
intérêts fade fiche de paye à remplir
côté employé le cesu peut être déposés à
la banque
il ouvre droit à une couverture sociale
des indemnités chômage et des congés
payés qui dit cheikh dix banques
le cesu se commande dans votre agence
habituels comme c'était le cas avec le
chèque emploi service la nouveauté c'est
qu'il existe maintenant un cesu
préfinancé vous le trouverez auprès de
votre entreprise votre conseil général
votre mutuelle ou votre caisse de
retraite
ces établissements peuvent financer une
partie du chèque avec ce chèque
préfinancer vous décidé de payer trois
heures de ménage coût 30 euros si votre
entreprise prend en charge la moitié
vous ne payez donc en réalité que 15
euros une somme divisé par deux grâce à
la réduction d'impôt offerte par l'état
les trois heures où vous reviennent au
final à 7 euros 50
l'entreprise aussi est gagnante avec 25%
de réduction d'impôt elle ne paye en
réalité que 11 euros 25
en tout vingt métiers sont concernés par
le cesu côté vie quotidienne c'est le
cas des travaux de bricolage de
jardinage de gardiennage de ménage pour
la famille vous pouvez payer garde
d'enfants soutien scolaire et assistance
informatique
enfin seniors et personnes dépendantes
sont concernés ils pourront financer
garde malade soins esthétiques ou encore
promenade d'animaux domestiques à terme
1 à 2 millions d'emplois seraient créés
d'ici 2010
deux heures de service à la personne par
semaine et par famille française c'est
un million d'emplois temps plein deux
heures on devrait faire mieux semblerait
que une évaluation plus proche de 320
milles d'ici 2015 et pas d'ici trois ans
est beaucoup plus raisonnable alors
c'est les résultats affichés par le
commissaire agen leur planche objectif
affiché lutter contre le travail au noir
seule condition le futur employé doit
accepter d'être payés avec un chèque
emploi service universel l'objectif on
l'a entendu c'est de créer des emplois
de limiter le travail au noir est bien
sûr de faciliter la vie quotidienne des
français il s'agit de leur proposer des
services à domicile moins cher et plus
simple d'accès illustration concrète
avec françois beaudonnet et jean-marc
nook spécialistes d'accord pour ces deux
heures de cours d'allemand à domicile
camille pourra dorénavant utiliser le
chèque emploi service universel une
nouveauté qui réjouit surtout celle qui
tient les cordons de la bourse
sa maman et ses économique parce que
finalement les courants veut revenir
beaucoup moins cher donc content moi
c'est vraiment génial
elle va donc abandonner le chèque
bancaire et elle a fait ses calculs sur
santoro de cours elle n'en paiera plus
que 25 premiers merci car les
entreprises comme cette pme pourront
choisir de prendre à leur charge une
partie de ce nouveau chèque pour
l'employeur un complément de salaire à
moindre coût ce complément de salaire
lui n'a pas de charges sociales
donc ça présente un avantage et depuis
1er janvier en plus au nord une
réduction d'impôt sur les sociétés que
nous n'avions pas auparavant
je paye ma femme de ménage avec ces
tickets qui me coûte en fait 50% de leur
valeur nominale puisque c'est 30 % sont
pris en charge par mon employeur
autre avantage le chèque emploi service
universel devrait inciter ceux qui
utilisaient déjà l'aide à domicile à y
faire appel plus souvent donc est
vraiment à suivre
et parfois je dis on va quand même je
parle les appelait pour ceci cela là
avec ses facilités qui arrive je
n'hésiterai moins ça va nous amener un
apport de clientèle beaucoup plus
important
donc automatiquement une masse de
travail beaucoup plus importante et on
espère pouvoir embaucher quelqu'un enfin
des créations d'emplois sont également
attendre chez de nouveaux intermédiaires
une dizaine de plateformes téléphoniques
comme celles ci viennent d'être créés
leur but permettre à tous les
particuliers de trouver un prestataire
de services et n'oubliez pas que vous
avez jusqu'à demain minuit pour payer
votre premier tiers provisionnel d'impôt
si vous n'êtes pas mensualisé même dans
sa version édulcorée la directive
bolkestein sur les services continue à
susciter des craintes trente à cinquante
mille manifestants se sont retrouvés à
strasbourg au moment même où le
parlement européen
débattez de la nouvelle mouture dans la
rue et dans l'hémicycle certains
craignent toujours des dérives libérales
jean-paul chatel et christine boss des
français des allemands des polonais
venus de toute l'europe
le cortège syndical est resté très
disciplinés objectif faire pression sur
les députés pendant leurs séances
plénières d'église n2 millier de
manifestants parmi lesquels une
délégation de socialistes français pour
faire entendre la voix des salariés
s'il n'y a pas de directive services
c'est l'ultra libéralisme qui va gagner
parce qu'à chaque fois le marché
s'arrangent tous seuls pour déréguler
donc nous avons besoin d'une régulation
européenne et cette régulation elle bat
paratek
exclu le principe du pays d'origine au
même moment à l'intérieur
al'annonce de cette manif
applaudissements des députés eux qui ont
réécrit la directive ils ont supprimé le
principe du pays d'origine
jugée trop libérale il est désormais
remplacé par le libre accès et le libre
exercice des prestataires de services
dans les couloirs du parlement entre
droite et gauche
le débat continue on applique à ses
travailleurs venus d'ailleurs la loi
française nom et ses 500 francs et la
loi française prévoit effectivement une
durée maximale et une durée légale dont
vous ouvrez la porte au dumping social
la mise en concurrence parce que les uns
pourront travailler quarante huit heures
les travailleurs français aussi peuvent
dans certaines conditions de travail et
jusqu'à 48 heures dont l'ancienne
directive demeurait une incertitude sur
le statut des salariés
elle est désormais levé ces salariés
sont protégés par le droit du travail du
pays dans lequel ils exercent l'issue du
vote après demain est encore très
incertaine car maintenant que le texte a
été édulcorée et bien ce sont les
députés les plus libéraux qui menace de
faire capoter le projet de nouvelles
manifestations contre le cpe le contrat
première embauche sont déroulées
aujourd'hui en france
mobilisation surtout concentrés à
toulouse rennes et lyon les villes où
les jeunes ne sont pas encore en
vacances de février
rennes vous le voyez sur ces images
reste la ville la plus active depuis le
début du mouvement entre six et quinze
mille personnes lycéens étudiants et
salariés sont descendus dans la rue et
ont bloqué les universités les
manifestants veulent maintenir la
pression avant le mouvement national but
7 mars prochain et puis manifestations
de colère de 600 salariés du groupe cède
à ecully ils étaient venus de toute la
france pour protester contre le projet
de restructuration présenté aujourd'hui
par le pdg du groupe
un projet vous le saviez qui entraîne la
suppression de 900 emplois en france
c'est à choisi de délocaliser une partie
sa production pour rester compétitif
face à la concurrence chinoise
un gang de kidnappeurs recherché en
région parisienne une centaine
d'enquêteurs est à pied d'oeuvre après
l'enlèvement et la mort d'un commerçant
il aurait été attiré par une jeune
complice quatre tentatives d'enlèvement
similaires ont été enregistrés depuis le
mois de décembre
sophie rodier france blessée la victime
agoniser au pied de ce talus près de la
gare de sainte geneviève des bois
le corps du jeune homme mort pendant son
transport à l'hôpital était couvert de
bleus blessé à l'armé blanche et brûlée
avec un produit inflammable
il y a trois semaines le jeune homme
vendeur dans une boutique de téléphonie
à paris est approché par une femme d'une
vingtaine d'années brune séduisante
selon un témoin et lui propose de le
revoir
il accepte en fait c'est un piège ils
ont donc échangé du numéro de téléphone
ils se sont donnés rendez-vous et lors
d'un rendez vous qui la lui
naturellement après nous n'avons plus de
nouvelles de sa part
nous avons eu des nouvelles par les
malfaiteurs ceux ci réclamaient une
rançon
d'abord 450000 euros puissant milieu les
ravisseurs n'honore aucun des rendez
vous fixés ils n'en étaient pas à leur
coup d'essai quatre tentatives disent
les policiers à chaque fois le même
scénario n'est pas forcément la même
séductrice plusieurs victimes ont décrit
une jeune femme dont voici deux
portraits-robots cette belle blonde a
même obtenu un rendez vous l'homme n'a
pas été enlevée mais tabassé dans un
parking
les ravisseurs ont été dérangés par un
témoin la façon dont les négociations se
sont passées
l'utilisation massive de vecteurs de
cybercafés les cabines téléphoniques
d'internet nous laisse penser que nous
sommes en face d'un groupe organisé
voici une photo publiée par la police
elle a été prise dans un cybercafé les
enquêteurs pensent qu'il s'agit de l'un
des membres du gang un gang certes
organisé maison comportements souvent
irrationnels dont les motivations
restent un mystère
la sécurité routière et les conséquences
de la politique répressive appliquée
depuis deux ans par le gouvernement
les automobilistes français ou perdus
l'an passé plus de sept millions de
points sur leur permis de conduire
certains sont obligés de passer par des
stages de récupération entre 230 et 260
euros la cession est parfois tous les
recours sont épuisées il faut alors se
tourner vers la voiture sans permis ou
le deux roues celles de sociétés
d'éditions il est signée vincent
fourcade yassine benzia net
il s'appelle yannick philippe ou encore
sandrine et tous sont fâchés avec le
code de la route vitesse ceinture
téléphone de vrais collectionneurs
d'infraction une petite ceinture j'étais
même pas sorti du parking qui vont
prendre les trois points pour la
ceinture et deux fois au même endroit
avec le flash à son absence
il me reste deux points sur mon permis
qui sont un peu en sursis pour mon
principalement pour
excès de vitesse non pour la fraction
uniquement excès de vitesse et sur les
dix 10 mois dernier j'ai perdu
pratiquement l'ensemble de mes points
pendant deux jours ils sont en stage de
sensibilisation aux dangers de la route
en contrepartie ils récupèreront quatre
points sur leur permis de conduire coût
du stage 240 euros ça fait donc 60euro
le point on a obligé travail et donc
pour travailler sur la voiture donc des
points donc il faut récupérer quoi ça
fait cher le point et je pense que du
coup ça limite le fait qu' il ya des
gens qui ai pas les moyens de se
racheter 3 millions 600 mille
infractions constatées en 2005 résultat
7 million et demi de points en moins et
54000 permis invalidés
une bonne nouvelle pour ce marchand de
moto car un automobiliste privet voiture
a tout du futur acheteur de scooter sans
permis ici en cinq ans les ventes ont
même été multipliés par cinq
dans l'ensemble les gens me disent bon
j'ai dû fermer grégory lui aussi a perdu
son permis il roule donc en scooter mais
il a trouvé la parade pour prendre à
nouveau le volant nourrir une voiture
sans permis
son véhicule lui manquait trop tout se
recoupe très brutalement à un pouvoir
s'en servir
ah ouais ça c'est un peu dur quand ça ça
mon cas c'est un quotidien surtout ça
fait de la peine quand on la voit tous
les matins garée en bas de chez soi
et depuis trois ans ce garage s'est fait
une spécialité la location de voiture
sans permis
45 km heure maximum qu'importe les sans
permis en raffolent cela représente
maintenant une partie une partie
importante c'est sûr de la clientèle des
voitures sont permis ça représente entre
20 et 25 % du potentiel location achat
du plateau et le marché de la voiture
sans permis a sans doute de beaux jours
devant lui
500 nouveaux radars vont être implantés
cette année au bord des routes
pour sa dernière journée à moscou
dominique de villepin était reçue
aujourd'hui par vladimir poutine
l'occasion pour le premier ministre
français de se positionner sur le
terrain international les deux hommes
ont notamment parlé d'une même voix sur
la question iranienne
mais pour les observateurs russes le
premier ministre était aussi un
présidentiable potentiel
arnaud bouter francis forgé sur la place
rouge la température chasse les bateaux
mais au kremlin l'accueil se veut
chaleureux avec le président poutine
dominique de villepin est venu aborder
les problèmes internationaux
le proche orient mais surtout l'iran qui
a décidé de relancer sa production
d'uranium
la france et la russie fixe un objectif
cet objectif c'est faire en sorte que
l'iran renonce à tout programme
nucléaire militaire devant les électeurs
français de moscou
dominique de villepin a défendu son
bilan économique et tester sa popularité
bain de foule
photos autographes et premières
impressions je le trouve très calme
vigilant mais je trouve avec une vérité
moins forte que je n'imaginais pour les
russes le cadeau de bienvenue ressemble
à un sacre un buste à son effigie et
lorsqu'on interroge sur la radio locale
la question du journaliste est sans
équivoque
vous pouvez surtout pas dire ça vous
allez me fâcher de faire beaucoup
d'ennemis
non non je vous en supplie alexis que
les coûts de moscou reste fidèle à sa
grande tradition
officiellement la france du anticipe
pour récolter des accords commerciaux
mais ce n'est pas tout car dominique de
villepin peaufine
sans l'admettre son image de
présidentiable près d'un million de
libanais se sont rassemblés aujourd'hui
dans le centre de beyrouth pour rendre
hommage à rafic hariri l'ancien premier
ministre assassiné il ya tout juste un
an
une mobilisation populaire qui a
confirmé que le sentiment anti syrien
reste toujours très fort au liban sur
place hamas ou là yann moix les larmes
d'un fils d'une soeur sur la tombe d'un
homme pleurait par tout un pays
saad hariri le fils qui a repris le
flambeau politique est rentré au liban
après six mois d'absence
des menaces pèsent sur sa vie n'est pas
question d'être absent pour commémorer
la mort de son père ce jour où son
cortège a sauté sur 500 kg d'explosifs
au coeur de beyrouth
ce matin plusieurs milliers de personnes
se sont rassemblées sur la place des
martyrs salué la mémoire de celui qu'ils
considèrent comme le symbole d'une unité
possible au liban et réclamer la vérité
sur son assassinat dans une cohue
indescriptible
saad hariri arrive sur la place et c'est
derrière des vitres blindées qu'il
demandera la démission du président
libanais symbole selon lui de la tutelle
de damas peu après dans son palais le
chef de la majorité parlementaire
libanaise nous explique pourquoi il
exige cette démission le président qui
est en train d'arrêter la naissance du
liban il est en train de de de faire
tous les intérêts de la syrie
et cet objectif saad hariri va désormais
le poursuivre depuis beyrouth il nous
annonçait qu'il mettait fin à son exil
sécuritaire en saluant massivement la
mémoire de rafic hariri les libanais ont
voulu rappeler aujourd'hui que mobiliser
unis ils ont pu obtenir une victoire de
taille le départ de l'armée syrienne
même si cette victoire a un goût
d'inachevé et la veuve de rafic hariri
se trouvait elle a paris une messe de
commémoration était célébrée en l'église
notre dame du liban dans le 5e
arrondissement jacques chirac et son
épouse avaient tenu à l'accompagner lors
de cet office
trois français nommé aujourd'hui juste
parmi les nations ce titre décerné par
israël distingue les hommes et les
femmes qui ont aidé les juifs pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale ils sont plus de
2000 en france parmi eux ivan beltrami
il a aujourd'hui 86 ans il vit à
marseille il y à 60 ans il avait hébergé
clandestinement cinq personnes ni que la
guise et benoît jourdain la photo figure
toujours dans l'album de famille le
portrait de son camarade jean bernard
qu'il a pu sauver 60 ans après il vend
n'a pas oublié ce jour de 1943 le
il va hébergé clandestinement son ami
juif il me dit je viens d'essayer de
rentrer à la maison
le concierge m'a dit que les allemands
venaient de revenir et je sais pas où
aller
j'ai pas d'argent j'ai pas mangé depuis
40 verges et les gens tu viens la maison
là je savais très bien ce que je risque
et où il est réfugié ou de partir en
camp de concentration a vu qu'elle va la
daurade à chaud c'est l'immeuble dans
lequel il a pris tous les risques
l'appartement lui est cher il en est
aujourd'hui propriétaire il n'a que 20
ans lorsqu'il se retrouve confronté à la
gay street est ici avec deux de mes
camarades
c'est un de mes amis qui éviteront long
terme ni la gestapo à tours le bon et
fouilles dans les maisons
alors ils sont venus jeudi cachez-vous
vite là dessous la gestapo est arrivé a
dit vous avez des juifs cuisinant moyens
aucun juif alors le type s'est tournée
il a ouvert la fenêtre s'est tournée il
a regardé il a vu qu'ils avaient rien et
il est reparti et eux ils étaient
dessous
quand les allemands sont partis que je
fais je vous assure je tremblais je
tremblais de peur cette médaille aux
jeux d'hiver c'est la plus haute
distinction qu'il aurait pu recevoir
elle le consacre justes des nations
finalement je me dis oh fin j'ai fait
quelque chose dans ma vie et non
seulement j'ai fait quelque chose dans
ma vie mais j'ai affaire à le peuple le
peuple juif qui est reconnaissant ils
vont beltrami un héros anonymes
à 86 ans il le dit il n'a fait que son
devoir d'homme plus de cinq tonnes de
cannabis ont été saisies par les
douaniers près de péronne dans la somme
la marchandise était cachée dans un
camion immatriculé aux pays-bas
la valeur de la drogue est estimée à
plus de 10 millions de romans l'image du
pub britannique en fumée et bien c'est
fini
les députés vie
de voter l'interdiction du tabac dans
les lieux publics en angleterre
l'angleterre qui rejoint donc l'italie
l'irlande la norvège malte et la suède
qui ont déjà banni la cigarette un
nouvel exemple qui pourrait bien
alimenter le débat en france nathalie
sapina patrick desmulie dernière
cigarette avant l'interdiction dans ce
pub de londres
pendant que les députés anglais vote la
fin du tabac de tous les lieux publics
les clients fument les pubs l'alcool et
la cigarette bien ensemble mais
peut-être faudrait-il des zones fumeurs
et non fumeurs
l'interdiction de fumer est tout à fait
nécessaire
l'angleterre emboîtent le pas à
l'irlande premier pays européen à avoir
banni la cigarette de ses pubs
c'était en mars 2004 depuis la suède la
norvège malte et même l'italie ont
totalement interdit de fumer dans les
bars et les restaurants en france c'est
la loi evin qui s'applique depuis 1991
pas de cigarette dans les lieux publics
dans les bars et restaurants séparation
des zones fumeurs et non fumeurs peu
étanches et peu efficace le débat
s'accélère avec une proposition de loi
qui a déjà recueilli 80 signatures
les patrons de bar han ont déjà pris
leur parti je pense que c'est possible
en france
peut-être par le même méthode de
fonctionnement il faut y aller petit à
petit mais je crois qu'on peut y arriver
ça sera peut-être un confort
supplémentaire dans un mois le ministre
de la santé devrait annoncer des mesures
pour durcir la loi evin ira-t-il jusqu'à
l'interdiction totale comme en irlande
et en italie
80% des français y sont favorables les
jo de turin avec d'abord cette chute
spectaculaire lors de la descente du
combiné le tchèque filip très cheval 21
ans vous le voyez a perdu l'équilibré
après une glissade plusieurs dizaines de
mètres le skieur a tout de même pu se
relever il la course a été interrompue
pendant un quart d'heure et côté
médaille
un espoir pour la france en patinage
brian joubert débute la compétition dans
la soirée avec le programme court
à 21 ans vice-champion du monde vise
l'or même s'il ne part pas favori en
tout cas il s'est préparé avec beaucoup
de minutie jusqu'à faire at elle veut
aller le voir aux dernières technologies
envoyés spéciaux à turin florent
gautreau régis mater c'est le jour ou
jamais pour voir la vie en rose et sans
vouloir lui lancer des fleurs on peut
dire que brian joubert a tout pour
passer une bonne saint valentin
à quelques heures du programme court le
poitevin est plus détendu que jamais
avant d'enfiler son habit de lumière
il refuse d'endosser le costume de
favori
donc je suis pas je suis pas un favori
c'est vrai que j'ai gagné une médaille
de bronze aux championnats d'europe
mais bon ceux qui ont l'impression ce
sont 500 devant moi donc surtout éviter
les pulsions la guerre des nerfs a
commencé hier à l'entraînement avec
plushenko l'épouvantail russe triple
champion du monde quintuple champion
d'europe est venu chercher la médaille
d'or mais joubert est en forme et il a
profité de la séance d'hier pour en
mettre plein la vue à ses adversaires
la fameuse combinaison quadruples triple
boucle piqué doit maintenant séduire les
juges il veut faire des beaux jeux et et
quel que soit le résultat l'essentiel
pour lui c'est de vraiment se faire
plaisir et puis à montrer de ski et ski
ce qu'il est vraiment joubert le
perfectionniste joubert l'extraterrestre
des capteurs sur tout le corps pour
obtenir une image en trois dimensions
qui permet de décomposer et figures les
plus compliqués voilà comment on repère
une vitesse de rotation insuffisante ou
un mouvement de bras intempestifs en
attendant notre james bond poidevin
rendez-vous à turin à 22 euros ce soir 2
minutes 50 de tension et de plaisir pour
pouvoir dire un jour
my name is joubert brian joubert et je
suis champion olympique
la saint valentin fête des amoureux de
nombreux couples choisissent cette date
en particulier pour célébrer leur
mariage images ici à saint pétersbourg
en russie une réplique d'un talent et
nuptiale impérial en glace a été ouverte
spécialement pour l'occasion bonheur et
longévité voilà ce que l'on peut
souhaiter à ces tout jeunes couples
longévité à l'image de jean et marie
thérèse
ils viennent de fêter leurs noces d'or
c'est à dire 50 ans de mariage
alors quel est le secret de cette union
durable rencontre en type signée olivier
théron et frédéric serrurerie elle avait
peur marie thérèse quand elle a dit oui
à jean c'était il ya cinquante ans
c'était hier comme si un philtre d'amour
effacé le temps qui passe
cinquante ans de vie commune des noces
d'or
après le grand tour ni de la vie marie
thérèse et j'en passe leur temps
ensemble hi facile temps perdu souvent
même pour la scène vannetaise est ce pas
là
des fois je parais week-ends et jours
laissé tout seul alors la saint valentin
c'est l'occasion de parler de parler du
couple de l'amour des crises et des
réconciliations et de cette tendresse
cette confiance que le temps à fabriquer
un toast à la mort
une promesse la saint valentin ça va
être tous les jours c'est sans doute ça
le secret de l'amour je vous le disais
en titre d' harry caul est décédé ce
matin à l'âge de 80 ans le comédien
souffrait d'un cancer du poumon
on se souvient de lui lancer rôle de
comique tendre et attachant une carrière
riche il avait joué dans plus de 150
films
elie chaste c'était en janvier 2004
darry cowl faisait son entrée à la
cinémathèque française
il en était le premier étonné courant
passe et dépasser moi je vais
sentiment de vivre quelque chose de pas
méritée du tout je pense alors pour
plusieurs générations de spectateurs
darry cowl c'était surtout le triporteur
tout vu naître son personnage d'harry
loufoque que c'est plein de défauts
zozotement bégaiement mentale du gabon
profond
le personnage qui est bizarre c'est
peut-être plein de lunettes
tout sens de cheveux bizarres bon et
hossa triporteur croix rouge et perd une
roue à porter une 2ème ou deux et rire
entry 3 froid ou triporteur 3 je trie
bons chanteurs tina brown
c'est avec la musique que tout commence
darry cowl sort du conservatoire de
paris diplômé en harmonie en composition
une se lance dans le music-hall vu le
cabaret avant ton père voyou et avoir
mon père bah alors d une vanne ps je
vais un homme il dit paris perd 1,9
voilà que l'évadé dalila il vient
ensuite au théâtre qu'il ne quittera
plus mais toujours en toile de fond le
cinéma ont presque cinquante ans de
carrière darry cowl joue dans 180 films
dont beaucoup nanar haut des besoins
impérieux d'argent parce qu'à l'époque
je jouais beaucoup et j'avais d'hors-jeu
je signais sans lire même ceux ci à des
films sans dire où je de juillet à quoi
t'en parenthèse bape à la marelle je
jouais à des jeux d'argent 20 ans le
cinéma semble l'oublier avant de le
consacrer en 2004 césar du meilleur
second rôle
darry cowl
non pas sur la bouche alain resnais le
fait chanter et lui refuse toujours de
se prendre au sérieux
jean d'une chanson you pourquoi avoir
compris mais bien sûr que non une
nouvelle carrière semble alors démarré
en 2004 dans le cou de la girafe
il fait une brève apparition sa dernière
au cinéma pour être au premier plan
darry cowl n'a jamais eu besoin d'un
premier rôle voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous de m'avoir suivi
tout de suite la météo patrice drevet
20h50 jurassic park 2 le monde perdue de
steven spielberg à demain en soirée à
tous
non